oh boy happy 2021
everybody we made it and this is my
first video of the new year
hi first of all i'd like to say thank
you guys for all of the support last
year last year was obviously crazy for
everyone
and i think that we're all hoping that
this year is going to be much much
better
obviously things started out a little
crazy this past weekend if you want to
know how i feel about it i was pretty
vocal on twitter
and on instagram as well so i'm not
going to get into it here
but my sister and i started a podcast
last year so thank you guys so much for
supporting it it's called same brain we
have same brain mugs i'll put a link in
the description if you want to check
these out and also if you want to check
out our podcast but why i'm bringing
that up
is because we filmed the podcast on
tuesday and
in the podcast we we said this we're not
sure yet it's tuesday that we're filming
this so we have a couple days we do
oh my gosh i hope your crazy news breaks
by the time this comes out
and if there is what's gonna happen you
know what's the worst that could happen
we that was uh
a clip from tyler who was actually
editing this video and he edited the
podcast
i don't know why we really thought that
we weren't gonna have any crazy news
so if you're wondering why we're not
talking about it in the podcast on
saturday that's because
we clearly recorded it ahead of time
so this being the first episode of ask
ij in 2021
i asked you guys on twitter if you guys
had any questions and of course
you guys came through with that hashtag
ask ij
let's just let's just get into the
questions like why are we even wasting
any time
talking about anything else this one is
from mark who is asking if we can collab
this year
yes mark count me in walter is asking
what do i think about the people that
use bots to buy up graphics cards and
consoles and sell them at a much higher
price on ebay there is a special
place for them and i will tell you where
it is
it's a place that burns it's fire
emily's asking what would i say has been
my favorite moment throughout my career
i would say
probably my favorite part was going on
my book tour because it really gave me a
sense of my audience obviously
i've been creating videos for a really
long time but i didn't actually ever
really see you guys now i see you
sometimes at vidcon but i was traveling
around the us
and to really get to kind of go to where
you guys are
was really fun and i do hope that one
day i will be able to do that again
here's a tweet from ryan who
is wishing me a good holiday what is
something that i'm looking
forward to most in 2021 and also what
are the chances you could convince henry
cavill to do a gaming video with you
i think we would all enjoy watching you
go toe-to-toe with the witcher himself
um okay this is a two-part question
something that i'm most looking forward
to in 2021
is uh it's quite simple it's being able
to solve a 4x4 rubik's cube i'm
almost there i've figured out how to get
all of the center
pieces to match but this was something
that really occupied
a lot of my time in 2020 mostly because
i i got a concussion
and obviously i couldn't go to the
doctors room in the freaking middle of a
pandemic so
i did what any person would do who
hit themselves in the face really really
hard with their iphone would do is you
google
concussion symptoms you tweet about it
and you get the feedback from you guys
the number one thing that they said to
do
was keep your brain active do some brain
games so i thought i've always wanted to
learn to solve a rubik's cube so
why not try to solve it with my
concussion to keep my brain active
and well i'm not a speed cuber by any
means
but we've got this one down next up 4x4
what was your question oh what are the
chances i can give in to henry cavill to
do a gaming video with me uh
i i don't know him personally i don't i
don't know him at all so
if he is interested in doing a gaming
video oh my gosh that'd be really fun
maybe me and jenna can get him on our
podcast
i saw that he had an nvidia 3090 that he
was installing on instagram so i'm
definitely
very jealous about that i wonder what
game we play what games he likes
does anybody know what games that henry
likes if so leave them in the comments
below i hope he likes call of duty he
doesn't really seem like an animal
crossing type of guy but
you never know speaking of the witcher i
actually did watch the witcher over the
holidays it was incredible
jeff is asking me what i feed maddie
maddie is my dog for anybody who might
be new here and
not aware he eats lamb he has a
freeze-dried
lamb diet that he's on now and it's
actually been really incredible because
he previously had a lot of trouble with
his diet he had so many different food
allergies and finally we put him on this
primal lamb
and he's been eating it he loves it and
he's gained a little bit of weight
that food must have been upsetting his
stomach and now he's a healthy
really meaty little boy chlfc
actually has a bunch of really great
questions here how often do you cover
accessibility
i don't actually cover it that often but
i do have all of my videos closed
captioned which is
i think a step in the right direction do
you think you cover accessibility enough
on your channel
i actually don't think that i do so i
think that should be something that i
strive to do more of in 2021. would you
consider making a disability special the
good the bad the important work still to
do in 2021 i would love
to hear some more of your suggestions
chlfc and also from you guys in the
audience as well
feel free to leave me some comments
below tweet me because i would love to
cover accessibility more
i think it is kind of difficult because
i'm not really sure what
to cover but i think the first step
would be
maybe talking to people who are
in the community and that would be able
to offer suggestions i really loved
hearing suggestions from you guys like
uh it was a while ago somebody told me
that they really loved watching my
videos because i was very descriptive
on when i was talking about an item i
would make sure that i said how it felt
you know like the weights and the feel
and just be more verbally descriptive
for people who aren't able to see what
i'm talking about and that's something
that i
had never even considered so i think
being vocal and telling your favorite
creators things that they can do better
like we're not going to be
taking offense to it like we need to
know what we can do to be better because
if you don't tell us like we don't know
colin is asking who is the lovely
sponsor of this
video colin is trying to set me up for a
sponsor if we have one i actually
should have had a sponsor for this there
is one that i could have integrated into
this but to be completely honest with
you i just
i didn't feel like reading the rest of
the email so
there is no sponsor for today's videos
but i am honestly
so grateful over this past year for all
of the sponsors who have sponsored my
content
behind the scenes it's definitely a
struggle i am
so grateful though to have still been
able to work
but a lot of projects that i had planned
for last year a lot of them fell through
so thankfully a lot of sponsors had
stepped up so super grateful for that
and super grateful for all of you guys
who
support the sponsored content because it
really does mean a lot to all of us
creators
brandon is asking what do you use to
organize your content
your video planning hmm
i wish that i had some sort of crazy
system
for you i basically use
the notepad like i use the notepad for
everything like on my mac i've seen a
lot of my creator friends who started
using notions so that's something that i
just recently set up the
the simplest thing for me right now is
just using the notepad because it's on
my phone
it's on my laptop my ipad and then if i
am
doing something that requires a pc i
will use microsoft's onedrive
because that's on my phone it's on my
pcs
and it's also on my iphone and i can
also get it on my mac as well so
that's something that i use a lot just
to sort of keep myself organized when
i'm doing cross-platform stuff
sydney is asking what is one piece of
tech that i'm most excited for
this year i'm really excited for uh
vaccine tech
in all seriousness i think smart home
tech is something that i'm very very
interested in ways to
kind of make the home easier to be a
work from home experience because
the way that the world was is never
going to be the same
for better or for worse i think that we
will find out so i think
just trying to work through what those
new ways of working
are will be interesting is there going
to be tech involved probably
i look forward to checking it all out
speaking of tech that i'm excited for
roberto blake is asking
what is the next great adventure for
justine hi
i'm justine and my next adventure i'm
going to ces
ces 2021 now ces
is now going all digital and it's really
exciting because they've kind of
re-imagined what ces was they took all
of the things that we loved about ces
the meetings the the keynotes and
the booths and all of this and kind of
turned it into this really cool digital
experience i'm very excited about it i'm
also
one of the hosts very fun very exciting
but this is the first time that i'm
going to be working on an
actual production since
maybe like over a year to be honest with
you because even at the beginning of
last year i think
it's been a while so i'm excited i'm
nervous but
i'm very confident in their covid
officer compliance
teams it's really interesting the way
that the entire production world has
completely changed and evolved
there's so much behind the scenes that
now has to happen to even be able to
have a production
put into place with that being said i'm
going to be so
extra careful but i'm excited for you
guys to experience the new
all digital ces bench fiddler my fellow
animal crossing villager friend
will you go to super nintendo world in
japan opens next month or will you wait
for
one to be built in the u.s let's say
there's no covet and you can fly
anywhere i would 100
be that i would have been there opening
day without a doubt like
you do you think there's a doubt no none
there's absolutely
not a doubt i would have been there i've
actually never been to japan so that is
someone that i've always
really wanted to go i used to travel
almost every single week
every other week very very frequently so
i'm definitely cutting down on that i'm
doing only
essential travel if that like if i don't
have to travel like i'm not gonna do it
rel k is saying folklore or evermore
obviously taylor swift was such
a highlight for me of last year i feel
like taylor
she really did reinvent herself with
both of these albums i
think that i liked folklore more
but i also don't want to say that
because i feel like they both kind of
tied together very well
that listening to them kind of both
together
is is kind of the way to go there's
really great songs on each album but i
think if i had to pick i probably do
like folklore more
i was definitely in a completely
different place when i was a city of
folklore so folklore definitely got me
through some really tough times
evermore really kind of picked up
where that left off but for me
personally being
in a completely different mindset from
where i was
when that album came out i don't know
it's really wild
how music can sort of mess with you
oh my gosh and i'm at the end of my
questions i
don't even know what to say now
it's over the video's over i guess thank
you for watching
don't forget to subscribe hit the bell
like this video how else do we end these
videos again
i'm not sure i think one of the things
that i need though is
a new end slate because this one is
quite old but for now
here's the old end slate i'll see you
[Music]
later
you